we are here
to celebrate nominees for their
wonderful work in canadian
cinema and television which is a lot
like celebrating
the northern lights you probably haven't
seen them but you've heard they're
amazing
you guys play enough hockey up here you
get that violent tendency out
oh yeah they make us try to play hockey
and then based on that i'm a huge fan of
hockey i love it and i love that people
don't get it
down in the states i love it i love them
why do they make why do they let them
fight i can't see the puck it's like
music to my ears
it's like good yeah get out of here do
you just get out of here i mean let me
let me watch it
do you remember when they lit up the
puck for a few years on tv oh yeah
that was you guys you know no but yeah
but the nhl
well no no wait are you wait a minute
wait a minute time out
time out time out the nhl is you guys
too so
all the owners had to agree with that
and you all had to be like we gotta we
gotta like expand this thing
we thought we'd funnel money into canada
and keep it here but you guys took it
over
like you tend to do but well i'm not
gonna apologize no i don't know you're
big on the yeah
that's just business dude you're acting
like we came and knocked you on the head
you know what we're about
yeah we wait wait a minute oh yeah wait
a second
fellow white person not native
to this country how did you guys get
this up here to the native americans go
oh
well we like these white guys you can
have all that land
jesus christ no ah i get it your [ __ ]
smells like maple syrup
up here you know what you're telling me
all right i'll go with it
let's talk about you now let me ask you
something another guy from canada has
come and invaded show business here
in the united states so many funny guys
come out of canada what
is it about canada that produces all
these comedians what do you think it is
um i don't know because when i'm in
canada no one's funny
do you think it's the long dark cold
winters you just had to find something
we don't have dark winters we don't live
in the arctic circle
but they're long aren't they they're
long and cold
and they're cold and really cold yeah
they're cold
so when you're a kid up and i want to
put too fine a point on it but they're
cold
let me tell you something my parents now
have been in uh canada 41 years
they uh they moved from india to canada
41 years ago i don't know how
they picked it or whatever but they were
like grenada and i was like okay well
maybe when you get there you'll be able
to say it so um
but when my dad first moved to canada he
didn't just want to live here you know
what i mean
he didn't want to be a guy that just
lived in canada he wanted to become a
canadian
and he thought that there was things
that you could do to become a canadian
like
like you just do a couple of things and
bang overnight you're a canadian you
know what i mean i used to come up with
these schemes when i was a kid
i remember one time when i was a little
kid he called me like son
come here
here's the thing with indian parents too
they they never just um
tell you directly to come and do
something they uh this it's just not
that kind of culture you know what i
mean
indian parents will not boss you around
like hey come here
because they they have salesmen built
into them you know what i mean
no matter what the situations they feel
the need to convince you to do something
you know what i mean
and sometimes they'll just take one word
and make it sound like a question
to make you come they'll be like russell
come
come come
so remember this one night right my dad
was like son
tonight we will become canadians
i said dad um i was already born here
i think i got it covered
okay but what's your plan he goes son
i have bought a barbecue
i go what are you gonna do cook the rest
of canada and we're the only ones left
no canadians like to eat the barbecue
i go dad they don't actually eat the
barbecue but
i think i know where you're going with
this
what's your plan he goes
tonight
we will have a barbecue in the backyard
we will invite all the neighbors
they will come over eat our food and
think we are a canadian
i said dad if they eat our food
they're gonna know we're not canadian
our food will have flavor
[Applause]
it's funny sometimes canadian white
folks get mad at that joke hey
you don't disarm boiled potatoes
right sometimes i put salt in that water
are you drunk
because all you did was ride a cooler
and you're sweating i am well it's
no it's hot is it it's hotter than a two
dollars it's got like
12 layers on it yeah i thought it was
going to be really cold
from canada this should be like it
should be springtime no i know i'm from
canada but you know i'm still a human
being
it's not like you revolve differently
[Laughter]
i'm from the frozen north yeah yeah it
gets colder than uh
it gets colder than here get your finger
on the panic button no i think it gets
colder than a vampire's demeanor
wow well good evening ladies and
gentlemen my name is jim carrey and how
are you this evening alrighty then
i grew up in canada
is there anybody here from canada
you know i used to get really upset when
i told people where i came from down in
los
angeles because i always got the same
response canada
wow must have been cold
now i just go along with them yes
canada it was a frozen hostile wasteland
[Music]
and there was much work to be done
if we were to survive the elements
after boring a hole through the ice
to find food my good friend
nantuck and i
would build an igloo to protect
ourselves
from polar bears and flying
hockey pucks
[Music]
then we would drink a lot of beer
and when man took was ready he would
tell me the story
of the great moose who
said to the little squirrel hey
rocky watch me pull a rabbit out of my
[Applause]
hat
[Music]
[Music]
this past april i began a tour of your
country
uh i started out in ottawa and went all
the way across
canada uh on a tour bus
and uh let me just say uh people ask me
uh you know what kind of mileage
do you get to a tour bus and it's
actually negative miles
we drove much of it backwards and and in
parts of your country
really doesn't matter if you do drive
backwards
and if you didn't laugh at that joke you
haven't driven across your country
i told many of my canadian friends
that i was going to tour your entire
country
and they said to me
why
and i said because i want to see it
and they went why
and they were correct i mean
from toronto to thunder bay
there's nothing
from thunder bay to winnipeg
there's less
there was no animals not one
nary a moose
i believe that your ancestors
after they left the east coast and
traveled west
killed everything in sight in order to
be able to put on enough fur
to make it to the west coast
in winnipeg this year i was told
that for five months the temperature
averaged
between 30 and 50 below
five months straight at what point
don't you get it
i was told that they had to cover every
piece of skin in that kind of weather
or it would freeze it's not
jack frost nipping at your toes you
idiot
it's god saying get out of here
even vampires can get out 12 hours a day
i was about 40 days on the road
and in that time
i saw the sun for 36 hours
every day it was gray rainy gray gray
[ __ ] gray rain gray [ __ ]
gray ring [ __ ] gray
at what point don't you people look up
in the sky
and think hey maybe i should slip my
wrist to see some color